[Music]  hurricane sandy of course has taken out  several of the big East Coast websites  did you know that people talking about  the damage that the hurricane is done  but it took out East Coast websites  leaving the entire nation running on  dangerously low levels of viral videos  oh my god yeah  fewer viral videos than we're used to oh  my god so don't worry your very good UI  are you laughing you actually seemed  concerned you're terrific  I live for those yeah well anyway don't  you worry all right  oh well let me tell you why don't okay  my word for oh don't worry  the world community has stepped up and  responded with some international viral  relief check this out  [Music]  [Music]  how do you feel now pal  I hate that guy I felt show it again  nobody's happy about that I feel bad for  the snake